what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time i'm here
with paulina ivailova marinova pompano
looking real sexy today all right don't
forget that lunch money is now sponsored
not to say that
okay but i don't listen i do what i want
to do lunch money is now sponsored by
block fi you can go and earn up to 8.6
apy
in an interest bearing account go get a
damn
account block five is awesome i'm an
investor i sit on the board
it's a no-brainer in my opinion what do
i know go do your research
go sign up blockbuy.com
before we move on i want to give a
special shout out
to an austinite named ramsey
oh yeah ramsay what up and he was great
max
what up oh max yes people in austin have
been very nice we keep having people
walk up to us and say hello
paulina was shook twice
all right what's up goldman okay but i
appreciate you guys watching lunch money
okay goldman goldman sachs has
recommended short positions against the
u.s
dollar arguing that the risks arising
from vaccine trials in the us election
are skewed to the downside
for the greenback they're recommending
short the dollar
what kind of [ __ ] is this of course
i've been saying that the whole time
goldman analysts said they saw
low odds for the most dollar positive
outcome
by the end of the year so what does it
mean to short the dollar
just think of every asset is denominated
in dollars so when you go to buy a stock
one apple share is worth x dollars if
you need more dollars in the future
to buy that stock that can either be
because the value of the company went up
or the dollar got devalued right so i
take a piece of real estate it's an
easier example
that piece of real estate probably
doesn't change from
uh july of this year to december of this
year but if all of a sudden you need way
more dollars to buy that same piece of
real estate
it's because the dollar got weaker right
you literally need more dollars to buy
rather than the real estate got more
valuable and so the whole idea is asset
prices are going to continue to rise
which means that the dollar will weaken
therefore if you're short the dollar
when that happens you can make money by
being long assets or shorter dollars
well that makes sense all right next
great for the dollar
all right quibby the short form video
app that they tried really hard to make
happen
jeffrey katzenberg is behind it six
months after launching
katzenberg is looking for a buyer so far
he has come up short according to the
information
over the past few weeks katzenberg has
pitched several tech and entertainment
executives about buying quibby
only to be turned down they include
eddie q
apple senior vice president of internet
software and services warner media ceo
jason
keelar and yeah he and his partner meg
whitman
are struggling listen there's some great
people that work at quibby
they're working hard they were put in an
impossible situation
because themselves no no the employees
did not
oh the company went out and raised all
this money and put all this pressure
on the company but the people there's
people who are in the product department
that are awesome there's people who work
in the content department they're
awesome
this is not a comment about any of those
people that work there
but take this dog outside
and we got to shoot it it's a wounded
dog i do
okay we need to take the trash out
that's what we need to do and the reason
is because
you cannot raise billion plus dollars
before you have product market fit it
just it doesn't work
you you literally can suffocate a
company with too much money or you can
start it with not enough
and in this case they suffocated the
company with too much money
starve it oh starving i heard started
yeah so you can starve a company because
they don't have money to run out of
money they eventually die
or you can literally suffocate a company
with too much money that's what happened
in this case
and again that's not a that's not a
comment about anyone that works there
it's just that in that situation it's
nearly impossible to be successful
go back to the lunch money and watch it
the one before
quevy launched and see what we said see
what i said mainly because i'm right now
okay mike if we're in texas
he's like shula okay
reach for the sky oh my god microsoft
has disrupted a massive hacking
operation that
it said could have indirectly affected
election election infrastructure
if allowed to continue it took down
servers behind trick bot
an enormous malware network that
criminals were using to launch other
cyber attacks
including a strain of highly potent
ransomware and basically microsoft
obtained a federal court order to
disable the ip addresses
associated with trickbots servers how
would it
attack the election well there's all
kinds of things that can happen from a
cyber
security standpoint with the election
you could literally manipulate
the election meaning that you can like
trick people into thinking certain
things with disinformation whatever
all like the bots on social media pose a
risk to websites that display election
information or to third-party software
vendors that provide services to
election
you can hack the actual voting machine
you could hack the thing the database
that counts all the vote i mean there's
all kinds of
uh risk points if you will but um
at the end of the day uh there's a lot
of money that goes into trying to
disrupt the elections there's also a lot
of money that goes into
trying to protect the elections so uh
it's just a cat and mouse game like
anything else
well that's dangerous good for microsoft
for figuring it out
okay next okay so basically
enrollment in u.s public schools is
dropping around the country
um so yeah six months after schools
around the country shut their doors amid
coronavia slog downs
fall enrollment declines comes schools
have been scrambling to improve remote
learning offerings and to adopt safety
procedures
to allow buildings to open for in-person
so i think that means that either people
are homeschooling
or they're sending their kids to private
schools
uh all i gotta say
what's the point of going on zoom at the
public school
just go on youtube well yeah but as a
kid how are you supposed to know what
you're supposed to learn
that's what a teacher is there for to
guide you through them your parents can
tell you watch this video okay what if
your parent
is working most of the parents are
working okay so how do you get your
it's just the parents are still sitting
there that's the point the parents are
sitting there
overseeing their kid on zoom
the parents don't just leave the little
four-year-old or seven-year-old at home
not everybody is like that well versed
in youtube education to tell their kid
watch this instead of listening to your
teacher
just saying i don't disagree with that
but what i am saying
is that it doesn't surprise me again
it's not that everyone is leaving public
schools
it's that a portion and maybe that
portion might be
five percent but i would argue that the
five percent of kids that are leaving
might be the five percent of parents
that are
positioned or had desire to help their
kid so it's not a binary thing it's just
of course if you're going to have kids
sitting at home the parents are there
look frankly a lot of parents are
probably like wait a second my kid's not
getting a good education
going to the school that they're going
to and so maybe they want to put them in
private school maybe they want to
homeschool them maybe they say youtube
does it better
again i think that homeschooling and
private schooling and even maybe youtube
is for a certain class of people
who have the money to afford that type
of
education is homeschooling dependent
on financial well-being
yes because it requires somebody to stay
home with the kid
and teach them and also let's say you're
the kid of like
immigrants and they don't really speak
the language like there's just there's a
lot of factors that
aren't that's all that's all fair okay i
think the point just being that
some percentage of people i don't think
that homeschooling is only for rich
people
right i think that it ends up being uh
people do it for different reasons
as well and you know for example
uh maybe your kid aspires to
uh be a professional athlete or maybe
your kid literally like
it wouldn't surprise me if we start
seeing parents homeschooling
their kids who want to be like um
uh these like influencers like on
youtube and things like that so it keeps
them out of school gives them more hours
to do that again but
if i'm a single mom and i'm working all
day how am i supposed to homeschool my
kid
you but my point is you are
homeschooling them right now because
they're not going to school
they're sitting there on zoom at home
yeah but
there is a curriculum agreed i agree
okay
all right we can we agree to disagree on
this we'll create a youtube
school and then you can say
no i'm not doing that because not nobody
wants to listen to me all right next
oh speaking of influencers influencers
are being taken
advantage of so now they're unionizing
okay so basically um
sorry i lost it yeah
yeah okay that sounds awesome
that was a great topic hold on a second
i'm trying to read really fast
right now waiting an industry trade
group named the american influencer
council was launched in the
u.s while in germany
some youtuber with more than 2.6 million
subscribers is fighting to have his
his recognized by uh the tech giant what
tech giant
it does basically at the end of the day
what's happening is there's a bunch of
influencers
they feel like they're being taken
advantage of uh in a financial
perspective
and what they're trying to do is they're
trying to create this union but
usually unions are focused on a
corporation or an entity and you
unionize
sometimes it's in an industry so
good yeah so the influencer industry
estimated to be worth 15 billion pounds
sorry guys this is a guardian article
it's in pounds not dollars uh estimated
to be worth 15 billion pounds
worldwide by 2022 can and does exploit
its workers many of them
being young women in 2018 tech reporter
taylor lorenz revealed that the talent
management agency speaker
owed influencers thousands in unpaid
fees the influencers
she interviewed had posted ad campaigns
orchestrated by speaker
but their invoices remained unpaid for
months so basically like these kids are
young
they're being taken advantage of because
they don't know what they're doing
basically
and people who do know what they're
doing are exploiting some of them
makes complete sense but do you think
that you a union is the right way to go
i don't even know what a union with
influencers kind of looks yeah it's like
an industry union
like the steel workers of america okay i
used to pass that every day in new york
shout out to the steel workers of
america yeah those guys looked
like they could they weren't playing
around all right next
there's a startup called bespoken
spirits
it says it's using science to produce
better whiskeys i'm already skeptical
um it just raised 2.6 million in seed
funding
from semiconductor mobile tj rogers and
baseball
legend derek jeter basically with bars
and restaurants closed or operating at
limited capacity
okay hold on that's not what we want
um while most whiskeys mature in oak
barrels for at least five years and some
for 30 years
um bespoken spirits founded by aaron and
material scientist martin jonusek
use technology that extracts the key
elements of the barrel that enhance
aroma color and taste in a matter
of days so you get whiskey in a matter
of days
that makes i don't like this why of
course people
they're going to try they're going to
try to decrease the inefficiencies
i don't trust whiskey not in a barrel i
don't trust
meat grown in a lab i don't trust
i'm cool with the whiskey i'm not cool
with the meat the meat in the lab is a
little weird but you know cool with the
whiskey you're still putting it in your
body and it was created
not right next
oh shoot that's it she don't have a joke
ready oh my god guys
okay so do you want to try your best
joke what is your best joke i don't need
a tony jokes what is a cow that has no
legs
a fat legless cow
ground beef didn't you say this one
already yes but it's off the top of my
head yeah it wasn't funny the second
time either that's fine
all right guys that's it for lunch money
today she's gonna sneeze in a second
but who cares we'll talk to you guys
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest bearing account or you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies on
their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends